K
ALL OVER THE WORLD.
>> ALL RIGHT, EARLIER TODAY,
ATTORNEY GENERAL MERRICK GARLAND
CONTINUED HIS CAMPAIGN OF
DESTRUCTION.
JUST THREE DAYS.
GARLAND ANNOUNCED THE
APPOINTMENT OF A SPECIAL
COUNCIL.
ANOTHER ONE TO OVERSEE
INVESTIGATIONS INTO THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
>> THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAS
LONG RECOGNIZED THAT IN CERTAIN
EXTRAORDINARY CASES, IT IS IN
THE PUBLIC INTEREST TO APPOINT A
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR TO
INDEPENDENTLY MANAGE AN
INVESTIGATION AND PROSECUTION.
BASED ON RECENT DEVELOPMENTS,
INCLUDING THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT HE IS A
CANDIDATE FOR PRESIDENT THEN
NEXT ELECTION, AND THE SITTING
PRESIDENT STATED INTENTION TO BE
A CANDIDATE AS WELL , I HAVE
CONCLUDED THAT IT IS IN THE
PUBLIC INTEREST TO APPOINT A
SPECIAL COUNCIL.
>> DOES ANYONE ACTUALLY BELIEVE
THAT?
THIS IS ALL IN THE PUBLIC
INTEREST.
THE SPECIAL COUNCIL.
KNOWN AS JOHN L OR JACK SMITH.
HE BEGAINES PROSECUTORIAL CAREER
IN 1994 AS AN ASSISTANT DISTRICT
ATTORNEY WITH A NEW YORK COUNTY
-DDA'S OFFICE BEFORE
BECOMING ASSISTANTMENT 1789
ATTORNEY FOR THE EASTERN
DISTRICT OF NEW YORK BACK IN
1999.
THEN FROM 2008 TO 2010 HE SERVED
FOR THE INTERNATIONAL CRIMINAL
COURT WHERE HE SUPERVISED ALL
WAR CRIMES INVESTIGATIONS
CONDUCTED BY THE OFFICE OF THE
PROSECUTOR.
THEN, HE RETURNED TO THE DOJ AS
CHIEF OF THEIR PUBLIC INTEGRITY
SECTION.
AND THEN MR. SMITH SERVED AS THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF LITIGATION FOR
THE HOSPITAL CORPORATION OF
AMERICA.
BEFORE MOST RECENTLY SERVING AS
THE CHIEF PROSECUTOR FOR THE
SPECIAL COURT IN THE HAGUE.
HERE NOW, MATT WHITTICKER,
FORMER TRUMP ACTING ATTORNEY ZEN
AND MIKE DAVIS, PRESIDENT OF THE
ARTICLE THREE PROJECT AND FORMER
CLERK FOR JUSTICE NEIL
GORSUCHEM.
GARLAND SAID THAT TRUMP'S
ANNOUNCEMENT AND BIDEN'S, YOU
KNOW, PROFESSED LIKELY RUN IN
2024, WERE FACTORED IN HIS
DECISION TO FAME NAME A SPECIAL
COUNCIL.  BRONZE THAT REQUIRED
BY TRUMP'S ANNOUNCEMENT ON
TUESDAY OR SOME HOW TRIGGERED
THIS DECISION?  JUSTIFIABLY?
>> I DON'T THINK SO, LAURIE.
IT'S.
GOOD TO BE WITH YOU TONIGHT.
HE WE GO AGAIN.
THIS IS THE LEFT'S FAVORITE TO
TOOL, TO APPOINT A SPECIAL
COUNCIL AND THEN LET THE MEDIA
BREATHLESSLY REPORT ON EVERY
TWIST AND 21ER TURN GIVING IT
SOME EVEN SUPER REJ MLSY.
MERRICK GARLAND MISSTATED A VERY
IMPORTANT FACT WHICH IS THAT
THIS SPECIAL COUNCIL IS NOT
INDEPENDENT FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.  THEY DEPARTMENT IS
GOING TO NOT LEAN USE THE
RESOURCES F OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND THE FBI, BUT ALSO
REPORT DIRECTLY TO MERRICK
GARLAND.  THIS IS A WAY FOR
MERRICK GARLAND TO SOLELY
CONTROL THE FATE OF DONALD
TRUMP'S LEGAL CASES AND I THINK
IT IS PROBABLY THE MOST PARTISAN
MOVE HE'S MADE TO DATE.
>> WELL, HE WHEN ASKED ABOUT THE
NEWS TODAY, A WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIALED TO TOLD FOX THAT THE
DOJ PAYINGS DECISIONS ABOUT ITS
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATIONS
INDEPENDENTLY AND WE ARE NOT
INVOLVED.
US.
MIKE, WE REMEMBER THAT STORY
THAT LEAKED TO THE MEDIA THIS
PAST SPRING WHERE BIDEN WAS
QUOTED BY SOURCES AS HAVING SAID
INSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE THAT HE
WAS FRUSTRATED WITH GARLAND.
THAT'S GARLAND WAS ACTING MORE
LIKE A JUDGE THAN PROSECUTOR.
SOME HOW THAT MADE ITS WAY INTO
THE NEWSPAPERS AND SUDDENLY
WE'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO BELIEVE
THAT THAT HAS ANY IMPACK ON
GARLAND?
THAT BIDEN IS HIMSELF
INDEPENDENT HERE.
>> AND BIDEN JUST MADE ANOTHER
PUBLIC COMMENT ABOUT THIS
SEVERAL DAYS AGO.
ALSO, RE, IT WAS BIDEN REMEMBER,
IT WAS THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE
THAT WAIVE PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
PRIVILEGE FOR THE MAR-A-LAGO
RAID.  THIS SPECIAL COUNCIL IS
GOING TO INVESTIGATION THE
NON-CRIMES OF OBJECTING TO THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
IF IT WERE A CRIME THE DEMOCRATS
WOULD HAVE BEEN CHARGED FOR
1969, 2001, 2005, 2017, WHEN
THEY OBJECTED TOO ELECTION IT'S
ALSO A NON, THEY'RE
INVESTIGATING THE NON-CRIME OF A
FORMER PRESIDENT TAKING A
PERSONAL COPY OF HIS
PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS WHEN HE
LEAVES OFFICE.
HE IS SPECIFICALLY ALLOWED TO DO
THAT UNDER THE PRESIDENTIAL
RECORDS ACT.
WHERE THE HECK IS THE SPECIAL
COUNCIL TO INVESTIGATION
PRESIDENT BIDEN HIS SON HUNTER
AND HIS BROTHER JAMES WHEN THERE
IS CLEAR SMOKING GUN EVIDENCE OF
FOREIGN CORRUPTION IN CHINA AND
THE UKRAINE.
>> MATT, IT'S JUST REAL, I
THINK, A HUGE MISTAKE.
FOR THE BIDEN JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
THIS IS GOING TO BE SEEN AS
POLITICALEM.
NOTHING.
I'M SORRY.
AND IT'S GOING TO BE SEEN AS AN
ATTEMPT TO GET A POLITICAL
ADVERSARY OFF THE FIELD BEFORE
2024, WHETHER THEY THINK TRUMP
IS WOUNDED OR NOT, PREVIOUS TO
THIS ANNOUNCEMENT.
AT LEAST HALF THE COUNTRY'S
GOING TO NOT BELIEVE THE OUTCOME
HERE, WHATEVER THE OUTCOME
ULTIMATELY IS.
DO YOU AGREE THAT THIS IS JUST
POLITICALLY AND LEGALLY A
MISTAKE FOR THIS JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT?
>> I DO.
AND I AGREE WITH MIKE THAT THESE
ARE LEGALLY SIEGE US CASES TO
START WITH.
AND YOU KNOW IF YOUTHENING ABOUT
WHY THE SPECIAL COUNCIL RULE IS
THERE, IT'S A DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE REGULATION, IT'S BECAUSE
THE INDEPENDENT COUNCIL STATUTE
EXPIRED AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE DIDN'T WANT ITS
BUSINESS.
WE END UP IN THIS MOMENT WHERE
IT'S NOW USED AS A WEAPON TO
HERTZ AND WEAKEN PLIGHT
POLITICAL OPPONENTS, BUT I JUST
DON'T THINK THAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE CAN STAND FOR THIS
TWO-TIERED SYSTEM OF GOGOS.
IF YOU READ THE SPECIAL COUNCIL
REGULATION, THE HUNTER BIDEN
CASE IS A LOT MORE ON POINT FOR
APPOINTING A SPECIAL COUNCIL
THAN HAD DONALD TRUMP CASE.
BECAUSE THERE ARE CLEAR
CONFLICTS WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE AS IT RELATES TO
INVESTIGATING THE FAMILY OF YOUR
BOSS AND THE PERSON THAT
POLITICALLY APPOINTED YOU TO
THOSE ROLES.
>> MAKING I WANT TO PLAY ANOTHER
MOMENT FROM GARLAND'S
ANNOUNCEMENT THIS AFTERNOON.
WATCH.
>> I WAN TO RECOGNIZE THE
EFFORTS OF THE MANY FBI AGENT
AND MANY OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT
PERSONNEL ASSIGNED TO THESE.
THEY AREWORKING COURAGEOUSLY AND
STEDFASTLY AND SERVING OUR
NATION HONORABLE MANITEE MIKE,
GIVEN WHAT WE'VE LEARN ABOUT
SOME OF THESE PROSECUTORS AND
AGENT GOING BACK TO THE MULLER
INVESTIGATION, FRANKLY EVEN
BEFORE THAT, WILL ANYONE BELIEVE
THIS?
I MEAN, IT SOUND LIKE IT WAS THE
ACADEMY AWARDS THE ONLY PERSON
HE DIN THANK WAS HIS AGENT AND
HIS MANAGER THERE.
ANYONE GOING TO BELIEVE THIS
STUFF?
>> ROAR REMEMBER, LAURA, ONE OF
THE ATTORNEYS ON THE PLEADINGS
ON THIS CASE WAS A FORMER
DEMOCRAT STAFFER IN THE SENATE.
AND SO, OBVIOUSLY , THAT
PROSECUTOR HAS A POLITICAL BIAS
AND SHE IS A PROSECUTOR NAMED ON
THE PLEADINGS.
THIS IS THE SAME JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT THAT WENT TO A BIASED
MAGISTRATE JUNG, BRUCE REINHARDT
WHO HAD JUST RECUSED FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S SIMPLE LAWSUIT
AGAINST HILLARY CLINTONEN SIX
WEEKS PRIOR BECAUSE OF THAT
JUDGE'S, THAT MAGISTRATE JUDGE'S
CLEAR BIAS BASED UPON HIS
FACEBOOK POST.  13 WENT BACK TO
THIS JUDGE SINKS WEEKS LATER AND
GOT THIS UNPRECEDENTED
UNNECESSARY ON A FORMER
PRESIDENT TO GET RECORDS BACK TO
WHICH THEY WERE NOT ENTITLED
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT HAS THE
ABSOLUTE RIGHT TO THESE RECORDS
UNDER THE PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS
ACT.
THIS IS STOKE FROM DAY ONE AND
IT HAS BEEN POLITICIZED AND
WEAPONISED AGAINST PRESIDENT
TRUMP SENSE DAY ONE.
>> WE ALL HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT
THE SPECIAL COUNCIL'S OFFICE,
ESSENTIALLY, WITH VERY FEW
LIMITATIONS, HAS AN UNLIMITED
BUDGET.
CORRECT, MIKE?
VERY QUICKLY, THEY CAN SPEND
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON
THIS, AND WELL, JUST LIKE THEY
DID LAST TIME WITH MULLER.
>> JUST LIKE THE MALAR PROBE.
MAYBE THEY CAN HIRE ANDREW
WEISSMAN AGAIN, THE PARTISAN
HACK TO BE THE TOP LAWYER ON
THIS PROBE.
GARLAND SAID THIS SPECIAL
COUNCIL ESSENTIALLY IS GOING TO
HAVE AN UNLIMITED BUDGET.
I WOULD SAY TO PRESIDENT BIDE
FUN YOU WANT TO SHINE PRESIDENT
TRUMP GET BACK INTO THE WHITE
HOUSE, INDICT HIM.
>> I THINK WHITE HOUSE
REPUBLICANS SHOULD SAY WE'RE
FOUGHT FUNDING THIS
INVESTIGATION.  WE'RE NOT GOING
TO T